hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Minecraft in this
episode we're going to be I don't know
what we're gonna be doing and that's
okay because it's still a lot of
exploratory I know I know what we're
gonna do
yes my food supply my food supply is
terrible and awful and I hate it and I
hate myself for building it
this is god-awful this looks terrible I
should feel bad for how I may just look
at the nightmare that this is it isn't
even right I deserve better than this is
this one mature we looks like no that's
what mature wheat looks like well then
anyway it's a piece of garbage and I
can't believe that I made this and I
actually actually I'm gonna deny that I
made it at all because this is just
travesty this is disappointing
I'm sorry farm if this makes you feel
bad or cry or whatever but you're
terrible and you should feel terrible
alright cool Oh what do I need to make a
farm I need seeds and yeah oh and that's
the last of my bountiful harvest down
the gullet she goes down the gullet she
goes done alright hoe time baby I'm a
farmer through and through
call me farm apply I think that this is
gonna be a perfect area for my farm what
I'm gonna try to do is to avoid square
shapes 90-degree angles are the devil no
I am NOT a part of it I will not play a
part to fiddle in the devil's works
something like that I don't know
time-lapse
[Music]
fine bye-bye
lamb chop sweet balls fell in the hole
okay as on purpose everybody that was
intentional I did that on purpose
all right we've cleared out the the top
area what this will be is my well of
course every good farm needs a world
guys I don't know if you can tell but
this is gonna be the well oh yes baby
first I'm gonna find out if there's
anything of value down in the well you
know any any you know children that have
been drowned in the bottom of the well
and are now cursed to roam the world
that journal II and torment oh well has
water he's got water perfect
what is this lead oh this can be cool
they'll be like a secret entrance in and
out of my well I did I dig this
[Music]
what the hell was that
hello secret well inhabitants was that
Enderman I don't know where are you what
have you done
who are you wait what I thought yes I
thought I was just in the well listen I
just in the well was it I just dis them
just where the well was labyrinth well
is a demonic mystical entity horrible
proportions
anyway I'm not really too concerned
about it it should be fine so I'm gonna
build this well and you guys are gonna
see it's gonna be lovely it's gonna be
my artistic a provisioning now there's
gonna be the well of do not go into it
this could be the well of a horrible
nightmares alright damn nice
that is nice and anyone who says
otherwise can go to herbicide I mean
heck look seein family-friendly replace
what I said was on the girls haha
alright I know I haven't grown any crops
yet I'm planned as a single seed and I'm
not exactly embodying the farm applier
here but I hold on to your horses I'm
gonna go get water now so I got my lake
and then I got my one bucket of tons it
kind of take forever to fill this well
sheep don't look at my well so big well
it's her way to make like sticks and I
bridge across this with sticks or
something and I do like a bucket hanging
in the middle how do I make like a rope
alright you know for now it's well it's
not a pretty well maybe if I made like
stairs how do you Xterra that's not how
you make stair how do I make stairs
make it a nice ramp up to the well I
don't know I had to look pretty I just
want a good Wow time to go to sleep
nothing well worrying about the I don't
have a roof don't sleep goes it goes it
goes the gullet oh ha no roof no problem
that's right burn you losers burn you
losers all right so I got my walkie and
all I gots that okay so the well can't
be like to the brim
that's not how wells work Wells have a
water line usually that water line shall
be just below
I don't want dirt in my well ah okay
booze is gonna take a while I could make
more buckets but my brain isn't good
enough to be able to math out the fact
that that would actually saved me more
time will save me more time in the long
run than then just going back and forth
so I'm gonna run repeatedly on these
long circuitous path sets that I could
also dig a hole in the ground and make
an unlimited source of water no I'm a
run I'm gonna run back and forth I'm
gonna run I'm running back and forth I
don't even really need a well yeah I
don't even really need a well but you
know it's what I'm gonna do maybe I
could pull water from the drippy drop
you know you can maybe I should have
been going to the river it actually is
pretty more proximal to my well than the
other source of water that I was going
right and I was going for hi can I get
up love to swim up my well alright well
that placement went a little scooshy I'm
hungry I haven't built any poor farm bad
farmer I'm a bad farmer guys don't judge
my well don't look at my well forget
I've tried to make a well I reached too
high I shop in the moon and I landed in
a well this is I should give up
ambition why do I try to make anything
pretty why do I try to make anything why
do we humans try to make art what drives
us to do such tasks the futility of them
must be a parent and yet we are driven
to create we have to it's almost as if
it's integral to our survival
to create works of beauty like this well
and this house I do not know why I
needed it to look good I don't know why
I needed to make it at all yet I did I'm
spending an exorbitant amount of time
simply crafting a well that will serve
no functional purpose in the game or my
real life and yet here I am repeatedly
drawing water from a fake river to put
into a fake well am I the fool or my
why's am I here to create or am I here
to destroy I am literally stalling for
time this is meaningless and I don't
know what I'm saying I'm just rambling
so everybody shut up I know you're all
weeping if the tears of the beauty of my
word all right I guess might wells just
gonna have a toilet drain in it and sure
whatever fine I'll take it it's fine as
my well it's kinda nice it's got a
running water little sound to it alright
your tissues and wipe your tears I know
you're just bawling at the wisdom I just
laid on your laps but shut up time to
destroy what I have created which is my
default state of mind a lot of these
clinic all right go away go to hell you
stupid mine I need to make blood what if
I put blood in the smoker I think that
would make nice smoky bread I got the
bread bud
all right brought in blood ingested
blood is good all right uh how about I'm
gonna make this yeah i'ma make it look
what is beneath me
why are there enemies beneath me I don't
like it
where are you where the heck are you you
pieces of poopy all right I'm gonna make
this look good you know why because I'm
gonna put a fence around it I don't know
if this is like gonna be my permanent
base I don't know if there's anything
else to explore beyond this but you know
I just feel like making it nice because
I you know whenever I play Minecraft
with the boys or anyone else for that
matter whenever I play Minecraft or
whenever I did play minecraft snot like
I play casually I I never take my time
to make things look nice I'm always in a
hurry to like try to make it the best it
could be and I think that's uh I think
that's missing the point of what the
game actually is the game is I don't
remember if like apples do fall from
these trees sometimes that used to be a
thing sorry just I haven't seen an apple
yet I thought I thought crews have maybe
only certain types of trees Oh knows I'm
destroying them but hey who cares I got
an apple I've never bothered trying to
make anything look nice so you know far
be it from me to enjoy a game and not
enjoy it to its absolute fully fully
fullest bulge in AHA my axe my ass dad I
have to punch this last one
all right no better you I did not want
to hold it but in here put in here shoot
there's gonna be a lot of sticks on
sticks I hope it sticks that make fence
I think it sticks but now that I've
sticked all my wood I don't know if it
sticks it might not be sticks it
actually might not be sticks how do I
make a fence there's no graphic
doubt of my whole I think I could go
back in my ol why haven't I moved
everything from my whole to my house I'm
an idiot
fans Jana birch fence birch fence that's
dumb
it also is not entirely spruce I missed
it
Bruce Bruce Bruce Bruce there we go
that's what I'm talking about baby
you nose buzzes all right cool we got
fence about the gate I don't know how to
make a gate Josh there's no gay
fletching table
what's a fletching table why do you did
a fletching table I know what fletching
is I'm not a nerd why do I need a
fletching table cartography whoa bouncy
engadin there's the gate right there
it's it's a gate poke was this oak nose
oke oke Oke baby oak baby i'm i am
betrayed Oh baby old baby and it's nice
night again how sure is the day/night
cycle good golly I can't farm in the
night it's stupid
all right it's time to fence it up
I believe you can put torches on top of
fence
I don't see why you would not be able to
do that so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna set the boundary of my area here
time lapse
[Music]
I don't know how to make a curve to save
my life I it's impossible
okay whatever it's fine can you make
dirt steer you make a dirt stairs odd
poop I think I just realized something
my old goal is dumb and I hate myself
someone having the fence run kind of
close to that I don't have enough wood
I'm digging this out with a hoe and
everyone who hates it go away I don't
have enough offense I definitely don't
have enough offense I totally don't have
an offense
oh you you you you you think you can
sass me the answer's no I'm gonna run
out - it's fine it's cuz I turned all my
oak - sticks okay we got wood so now we
need to make
I need more got it all right so now
we've got more than enough fence and buy
more than enough I mean more than enough
I don't know why I got this many but
it's okay I'll need more gates
eventually I know but I know it probably
easier for me to just bust out a tool
and I'm busting a justification for
wanting to try to not bust out a tool so
I shall shut up and bust out said tool
lick see and kick up the dramatic music
we're about to finish baby
[Music]
oh there we go nice nice nice yes yes
yes yes yes this shall be my farm I know
it looks more like a ranch than a farm
but that's because you're your third eye
is not open and it will be open soon and
you'll see the farming I'm starving
this is a lot of work that's just so
much work for what amounts to like
basically nothing it's it really is
quite a significant amount of work I
never would have thought that I would
put this much effort into anything let
alone a farm but my god when I tell you
I'm about to have a plethora of goodies
to enjoy I'm gonna be enjoying them for
eons also I discovered you could make
these too wide apart the farm for the
wheat hmm I'll finish it for the fans
during thunderstorms really I didn't
know there were thunderstorms well the
sun's going down is our night already
hello hello ah they're dudes my dudes
yes night it's not baby it's it's nice
it's my it's my they're coming for me
okay cool
all right baby all right you know what
else I'm gonna do you know what else I'm
gonna do you know else you know what
else I'm gonna do watch this
three buckets I am in fact a madman oh
wait what's that five buckets how about
we go deeper down this rabbit hole how
about we go even further beyond eight
buckets do you think I would stop at
merely eight 10 buckets mark you're
insane you say what a waste of iron I
say I don't literally can't stop someone
please save me I can't make it I made
sixteen buckets
I was so ludicrously stupid everybody oh
my god so dumb why did I do it
[Music]
I look like guys you know I might be a
little absent minded and slightly AVD
most of the time I I don't know why I
made sixteen buckets
I'm not even pulling water from my well
look just leave me alone let me wallow
in my misery
can I get unlimited water after like
probably like yeah can you smell
something down into its base components
can you recycle in this game is this
game at all cycle
conscious no I that's my whole I need do
this no can't keep up with my speed hmm
that's pretty good
no I was so close to done I was oh no oh
no oh you can't do that to me Oh what's
wrong with you ho
that's illegal oh wow ruined my life oh
okay whatever it's fine
all right there's my well cool that's
good I'll go make another ho I guess I
don't have to I we're good we're good
baby
I have no sticks I used it all okay cool
all right well this has been an
emotional journey I'd say this episode
it's been a little bit of a tumultuous
one can you spell tumultuous lick C and
hit him with tumultuous it's been a
little tumultuous spend a little bit and
boom almost done I forgot planting is
part of the process let's plant up a
storm buddy
all right oh yeah here we go yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes oh no no no not
like this no no no no please finish
finish finish finish better face yes
there she is baby there she is
[Applause]
that my friends is a thing of beauty
[Music]
this is the start of something
incredibly oh my goodness
this is nice that's nice that's nice
right there this is gonna be something
special I think I'm starting to discover
what it means to craft this world to
mine and then craft so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to check out more minecraft that
I've done there's 69 episodes of drunk
minecraft linked in the description
below and cloak brand is still doing its
minecraft club by the way if you haven't
checked out minecraft dungeons 2 I've
played that with Bob and Wayne thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]